mid turret getting a bit low and there's
the gates are gonna try to go in on to
Apple Apple immediately with that
slicing maelstrom everybody is there
though oh the ban in the world you get
to be that good I want to know man guys
it's about time we gave support
champions some love I mean it's easy to
talk about flashy champions like Caixa
irelia or a collie but support champions
can kick ass too
that's why this week on best of we're
celebrating the best of those guys who
have your back in Lane the best of those
champions that would rather sacrifice
themselves than leave you to die in a
team fight the snow type we must get off
this ship before it's too late
he seems to be alright leave him or
we'll never make it
his fate will be the same
and guys if you want to support this
video see what I did there and get a
cool t-shirt just like this well we've
got this one and plenty more available
at the score eSports new online lurched
department a link to that will be pinned
in the comment section below
look at that subtle off-white coloring a
tasteful thickness on that oh my god it
even has a watermark and of course guys
we want to hook you on this content
right off the bat so let's start this
video with some day gasps hooks from the
likes of Thresh and Blitzcrank at early
stage of the game but I'm putting it out
right here that was predicted death
sentence that was amazing whoa out of
bunny foo foo and the flame it jump
doublelift has two abilities that can
sell feel but don't win this bunny
[Music]
himself another shot minions are
blocking away
is the rocket crab he's looking at take
a bow igner overshield built up on
bloodthirster Laos until it stands still
a little bit more one of Draven's pain
points it's gotta know where the axes
are going and now you took on a car so
beautifully stopping the hit on such a
suitcase they get a killing the fight
now RNG vitality but not my game clinic
right now entirety of Italian now again
snoozy but he can't do much the gun is
locked
vitality pickup the way
I'll never give up
tell you what an eagle egg is in Europe
Arif yeah the Summoner but we got to see
the land upsides of it
he's got the pole looking for the play
bottom spends gonna be chillin smited
lira decides okay that's fine we're just
gonna go home hit the MC book comes Bru
and now both TSM bottom laters gonna be
in some trouble fin still try to walk
away from this limit Apollo's got the
damage one more auto attacks to do it
can defy who rips the soul right out of
them the nice Lisa Fischer into the
exhaust combo to keep alive for long
enough to allow Kuro to make that
mistake in the plane now it looks like
they're on the chase for pawn but again
they're chasing at Casa de is a very
hard thing to what is that he's trying
to turn it around now but he gets oh
this guy oh that was it see oh my god
l'ainte get get release in this is all
about the green tea setup
[Applause]
let's see
no summoners regarding devil though
that's gonna show himself so it's gonna
push it out there there is it going
aggressive he gets the killer feet seems
to escape the same thing amazing this is
going to be the back and forth peanut
just on the outside a quick shield
coming in in the heel fur ball bakers go
ahead put the crew right through the
uprights and he's going to say walk this
way the team's gonna have to meet him on
the other side the cleanse comes up the
left the rest of the team is left
wondering and misfits is looking at
parent here we go on to the front lines
they are there are going to be taken
down Horry out of the picture but now
TSM found their team fight on the front
lines Bowl is gonna drop just back this
benefit looks to at least get something
in return
spin is down a big pick there onto the
enemy ad carry clutch gaming three
versus four but they've still got both
their big damage dealers TSM so their
retreat haven't been looking for the
member move not able to find it on the
bureau not bad
Paco is a freaking monster this land
fortresses here oh it's it seems rather
inconceivable that blitz is gonna be
able to have a chance to come back one
suck again getting caught of it
how does he hit every single one
how is that possible you know I feel
like after madlife retires from League
of Legends uses gonna become like a pro
fisherman or something no no no it's
gonna just pass it and catch like
whatever he wants it's like it's time I
went a six foot muskie no is that what
he's going to rapture straight to heaven
baby whoa there are few things more hype
in League of Legends and a good hook but
of course guys there are other ways for
a support champion to turn a teamfight
on its head or initiate one here's what
we're calling the best of badass hero
support plays fnatic they need caps to
be able to start taking out these
carries and having him get caught like
that feed the buff back over not a good
look for them at the moment is Brocks a
little bit occupied on cyrillus Oh move
Oh egg nah no I love it
legends that went on vacation hopes not
getting caught out though no ultimate
available oh it's absolutely sick what
see you look back wow they're literally
toying with their food right now one
kill Pratap already by Xfinity now movie
in the front line as well a nice target
was out of the BART o for phantom our
debate and temper your expectations
energy because you're all going down
another three kills come through only
two is alive the slow out of darshan
does he want to chase the one the answer
is yes he does the A's come fruit bang
really taking that big hit in the laning
phase and not being able to make
teleport plays in the bottom fnatic is
at everything their way out rain of
against courts out equalizes available
Mario Riedel and the Norbit does not
manage to connect they find the killer
fantastic control the map so rain over
here getting caught while the rest of
the team Huddle's through but they get
caught they group up right on the canvas
Bombay from made it in by fibbin there
they wanted to take out the LeBlanc and
yellow star plus hooni jump on the
opportunity the bot Lane took a pretty
rough trade around leona from behind is
actually abysmal you need to be able to
go aggressive or you can't do anything
while they try to get to the front
already a knight goes down immediately
no flash forward but the heel comes out
they turn to wolf his bang feels like
can get back into the fight just a hunch
over a stove johan samba one more shot
as wolf wants the glitter lands
sweetie the taco stealthy
watched on a dog
misfits pull the trigger yeah I
definitely can't take too much from it
but here we go oh um they can abate the
death mark out if Evan who's enough back
away from this one on the hunt now
popped looking for rain over but still
extremely dangerous to try and jump on
all teleport put a woman Oh huge Timbers
done and that is going to be fnatic
getting the turn around hoody
unstoppable they're looking for a boil
they should be able to find him and this
tower should be going down as well
massive plate from fnatic two kills
tonight
the dragon will probably not be
contested even though all oh my god is
going for the whole team coming in
it's wild turtle still up wins fusion
bottom every pickaxe here but into the
PS sort of wildturtle the kill falls
over to expression with the ignite in no
way that just happened yeah I got any by
word the confidence in TSM right there
to go for that combo is ridiculous it's
doing a really good job
come on a champion that's difficult to
farm with m/sec gets into a tussle with
cloudtemplar guns oh he needs to run too
he gets all did and now gave my mom
coming into the spirit rush in sec other
position gets up Oh doesn't get on the
lantern what a wild throw from madlife
an amazing play I didn't even know you
could break dark passage with the wild
growth that is so cool guys there are
hooks there are initiations and there
are teamfights
but you'll never love a support more
than the moment they save you a trip to
the fountain here is the best of
supports doing what they do best saving
your ass playing next class with the
wall art a look to make something happen
personally to be able to escape one
target that's the knock-up he's gonna go
forward with deed though has been
I spent left out ko debacle in with the
ranch's boy wants a flip hurts right
back in the team man it's all about
devil with deep once again saving the
day with the tahm Kench ultimate you've
gotta love the use of that interaction
and there's a teleport in bottom impact
is down there cutting off those could be
bad do you see a double have found a bit
of trouble - gonna prop impact will keep
testing it bounces on his head double it
this is the net many [ __ ] a chasing
down
by oh god is in the house SS was praying
to his Lord and he came to save him holy
moly a diamond company you know the
doctor on there the crude spirits refuge
zip and I'm trying to protect him I'm
still coming out Lola is still looking
to going beneath the people vital one
more in [ __ ] Zagreb like right but
ultimate might save Josh on oh boy hello
he actually carried the bar through the
legs down low bro are you kidding me
I don't look to pick up the first turret
here as well the bank might have
overcommitted oh my Wolf's flat that fan
is able to block pretty much everything
from getting on the bank you could just
walk after work yellow penis okay oh
there it is Jack he tries to get yellow
Pete but krepo ass wallet second
decision of head but very well played he
got the horns on that one 19 minutes on
to this 4 to 3 they're looking to make
it possibly four before here krepo Febby
bids now at Rumple out of mana barreled
down he's drunk Niels gets two more
kills pet killer loses Life and reply
but origins solo dragons not over yet
Trevor here Panik is behind enemy lines
and Hardy and they look for them while
let's see reckless is on myth the
amazing son who knee where can Reckless
Getaway he's been stunned up Niels it's
gonna be able to get one soon save
reckless his life and yellow so with his
lost drop of mana secures the disengage
oh he's off that bio frost in a bad spot
tempered fades their classes away and
hits Expedia on the journey he may be
able to get out he will get out we see
very early focus on the bottom side
c'mon today we know this the strategy
often from HQ camphor and he's taking a
very different route over the wall he's
going in was gonna be looking for the
knocker
bag gets him he's got the red buff
ticking that's a flat forward the hoof
is gonna be able to play them back with
will continue to chase to SKT wolf
oh good good sweep from Adrian hook not
gonna land the latter range but I like
the angle from by across fence Karin
still want to eat it looks Vera try to
think of dam isolation Devin is enough
what the dumb again sighs it's hard
see you later five kills for Spence
Karin he is popping off I said at the
start you good jacy's juggle up or rinse
the shut down it makes it look good well
guys that about does it for the best of
hero support plays in League of Legends
now you'd really be my hero if you
supported this video by dropping a like
leaving a comment and of course
subscribe to the channel I'll see you
next week @e pose what's that just this
okay yeah yeah that's good let's do that
let's do that let's do that
[Music]
I don't know